all right so we're about to talk about
Resident Evil Revelations the only time
I actually enjoy talking about Resident
Evil when it's one of the video games
Resident Evil Revelations has just come
out for the PlayStation 3 in the Xbox
360 now this is a port of the original
Nintendo 3ds game now I didn't get a
chance to play the original game but I
was really excited to play this game
because I loved Resident Evil the game's
the majority of them not all of them are
great but for the most part I really
enjoy that series my favorites of the
series were always the first one and the
fourth one which is why Resident Evil
Revelations really struck a chord with
me because to me it's kind of like the
best of both of those games in this game
the lead character is Jill Valentine but
she was the main character of the first
one unless you played as Chris chris is
also in this game as well as a whole
bunch of different other characters and
you take hold of all of them and the
interesting thing about this game is
that it tells the story in a nonlinear
sense you will actually hear about a
past event a character might refer to
something and then in the very next
scene you might actually be playing out
that event as whatever character
experienced that event there's lots of
different characters that you play in
this game but there is still a central
story and that central story takes place
on this cruise ship in the middle of the
ocean in the middle of nowhere that is
now abandoned completely infested with
monsters there's a virus that's broken
out amongst this ship these zombified
creatures are everywhere and it's your
job to try to get to the bottom of what
happened I was really surprised how much
I enjoyed Resident Evil Revelations
certain aspects were very similar to the
first game obviously Jill Valentine and
Chris are back as characters but there
was still that great creepy vibe
throughout the hallways of this ship and
you hear these noises and doors would
open sometimes on their own sometimes
candles would light themselves all these
creepy things happen as you play the
game it actually really starts to affect
you and you're into this world and you
feel really engrossed in being in this
ship and one of the best things about
the Resident Evil games in my opinion
has always been their use of atmosphere
and location especially the first game
with that mansion and everything around
it Wow I really felt like I was in there
like I was just lost in that house in
this game I felt that very similarly
except about the ship and in that way it
really reminded me of the first game
about this that's more similar to the
fourth game is first off the cam
perspective it's behind your character
it's not like a set angle that doesn't
move as you enter a certain room and the
game also does have a fairly good focus
on action as well it's not all entirely
survival horror there are some big
action set pieces in this game
especially when you go back to other
levels and play as different characters
who encountered other tragedies in other
places elsewhere and other times those
levels are always a lot more
action-packed than the ones that are in
the boat also another thing that I love
is this goes back to some of the more
puzzle solving elements of the first one
you know the mysteries and finding books
and reading through manuscripts and
trying to figure out what people are
saying and everything there was one
scene in this game that really scared me
you were reading this book and you could
see that whoever was writing at this
time we're starting to turn into a
creature as they wrote because their
writing gets more and more strange and
then like she looked up and there was a
frickin creature just right there after
reading and I was like oh my god Wow
like that actually got me which was very
shocking to me because you know it's a
video game and that doesn't always work
that way but that got me good job
Resident Evil Revelations it takes a
while to get used to which buttons are
what sometimes at first sometimes you
have to scan things that are in a
certain environment kind of like in
Metroid Prime we could walk around and
scan everything with samus's helmet you
have this gun that scans things and it's
cool because you can up your percentage
of what you've scanned in the
environment sometimes you can find like
hidden items and stuff the thing that
was annoying is that sometimes it was
hard to remember like okay is that the
grenade or is that the scan and doing a
quick turnaround by just holding down
and pressing X on the ps3 controller God
actually was fairly challenging and
didn't really work a lot and one thing
that did annoy me at first but I
eventually accepted because you can just
skip through them at the end of each
episode because the game is broken up
into a series of episodes it does like a
previously on Resident Evil Revelations
thing as if you're watching a television
show and it sums up the last episode the
thing is if you just played it watching
that is rather tedious but you can skip
it so I eventually forgave that but it
seemed really weird at first my captor
that in the game also in the middle of
the game I actually recorded this on my
iPhone because I found it absolutely
hilarious you're in this really serious
situation and you look over and this one
character next to you is just dressed so
idiotically I could not stop laughing
when I saw it so here's me and there's
my partner
apparently she is a
stripper I mean like she's on some
rescue mission right now I don't
understand what's happening I just
thought that was kind of stupid it was
so obvious let's just make the girl look
all hot and sexy for no reason but
overall I really enjoyed Resident Evil
Revelations the game was a lot of fun
the story was interesting well
convoluted just like all the big
Resident Evil games are there's always
this big humungous government scheme
that you don't really understand fully
but it's really about the gameplay and
how much of the story feels as if you're
invested in it and in Resident Evil
Revelations I was consistently invested
in the story of the game while playing
it I had a lot of fun at the atmosphere
and I liked the fact that it combines
certain elements of the best Resident
Evil games I'm going to give Resident
Evil Revelations in 8.5 out of 10 it may
not stick with you as well as past
Resident Evil games but I think it's a
lot of fun and if you enjoy the series
you'll probably enjoy this one too
thanks as always for watching guys and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my nice